the georgia state house should consider
getting even tougher than they are
already doing
no then they already are doing can can
we do that is it possible
for an answer to that question we turn
to dr
joe biden so say it with me
si say quad way the future is
ours thank you yes we can do it
si se puad way
no no se puad way if we're talking about
jill biden joe biden was not able to do
it
the democrats have always been good at
pandering particularly on racial issues
this is why they try to sprinkle their
conversation with
spanish usually it doesn't go very well
if you watched the first couple of
presidential primary debates during 2020
on the democrat side
you would have it would have been like
you were in a sixth grade spanish
classroom
with cory booker trying to babble out
some broken spanish
beto o'rourke that was unfortunate and
isn't he spanish
he's hispanic he should be able to do it
and now joe biden butchering that
language
uh how however you know it's funny i
mentioned the joe biden thing in part
because
we for the past four years had a a
first lady who spoke something like five
languages maybe more
very elegant very urbane and the entire
left just tried to make her out to be
some kind of
evil bimbo but jill biden
who she i'm not going to attack joe
biden she might be a nice lady i don't
know
but they try to make her out to be like
a rhodes scholar you know and
for a while whoopi goldberg on the view
was campaigning for her to be
the surgeon general because she didn't
know what kind of
degree jill biden had and so anyway just
just to note the double standard to the
question though
that joe biden i guess is trying to
allude to can we do it i want to i want
to apply that question
here in the question of uh the
woke companies can we as conservatives
say no to the companies can we say hey
you've gone too far you're trying to
undermine our system and we're not going
to let you do that and we are going to
wield the power of the state
when the people have given it to us
against the
allegedly free market i think that
phrase has been stretched beyond
all meaning recently but can we wield
the power of the state as conservatives
to undermine the working of the free
market when those actors in the free
market are trying to subvert our
republic
my answer si se puad way si puadue
i don't know i don't speak spanish any
better than than joe biden does of
course we can
conservatives by writing a blank check
to the corporations
we have given away the game because have
you noticed that the big corporations
around the country
are pretty into woke politics have you
noticed that there are some of the
leaders
in terms of pushing wokism around our
country
why would we let them get away with that
because we've made some idol out of
a misbegotten conception of free markets
i love free markets
in their proper place toward the actual
end of politics
the free markets are not the end of my
politics they're an instrument
toward a good polity toward a
flourishing regime toward justice which
james madison says in the federalist
is the end of government see saipuadway
sipua mucho mucho i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you